hey guys
welcome back to another video by simply
learn
in this video we'll look at some of the
key differences
between angular and angularjs
now if you haven't watched our videos on
angular
go check them out i'll link it in the
description box below
now angular and angularjs are used
interchangeably but they're not the same
so to learn about the differences
continue watching the video
oh but wait before we begin if you
haven't subscribed to our channel
already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
now here's what we're going to be
learning first we'll look at what
exactly angular is
then we'll understand what angularjs is
finally we'll differentiate the two
based on architecture
language expression syntax
dependency injection routing and speed
so let's begin now what exactly is
angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework
written completely in typescript and
maintained
by google now angular provides a
standard structure for developers to
work with
it enables users to develop large
applications
in a maintainable manner
so what exactly is angularjs then
now angularjs was initially developed by
misco hevery
in 2009 it was built to ease the
development and testing of applications
it was developed to address challenges
faced in forming
single page applications now although
subsequent
versions of angularjs are what are
collectively called angular
they have some differences so let's go
ahead and look at them
first up is architecture now angularjs
supports a model view controller
architecture
the view processes the information
available in the model
to generate the output in case of
angular it uses components and
directives
now components are the directives with a
template
next we have languages now angularjs
was written in javascript while angular
is written in typescript
now typescript offers features like type
declarations
and benefits of es6 like iterators and
lambdas
the next difference is with respect to
mobile support
now angularjs was not built with mobile
support in mind
whereas in case of angular this feature
is supported
moving on is expression syntax
now to bind an image or a property or an
event with angularjs
you have to remember the right ng
directive
in case of angular it focuses on the
parenthesis
for event binding and the square
brackets for property binding
talking about dependency injection
angularjs
does not use dependency injection while
angular
implements unidirectional tree based
change detection
and uses the hierarchical dependency
injection system
this significantly boosts the
performance of the framework
next up is routing now angularjs uses
the route provider.when
method to configure routing while
angular
uses the route config object lastly we
have speed
by providing features like two-way
binding angularjs
reduce the development effort and time
however by creating more processing on
the client side
page load was taking considerable time
while in case of angular it provides a
better structure
to more easily create and maintain big
applications
and a better change detection mechanism
now angular 4
is the fastest version yet so with that
we come to the
end of this session these were some of
the key differences between angular and
angularjs
if you have any doubts or queries
regarding this topic
let us know in the comment section below
thank you so much for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here